how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and now we have less than a week
until one division airs on disney plus
and if you haven't heard we are getting
a
two episode premiere again i'll be
having a watch party on my youtube
channel if you all want to join me in
watching it
and it sounds like the show is
absolutely fantastic as the reviews have
come out today the embargo is lifted and
the people who have gotten early
screening of wanda vision have been
allowed to post their reviews
and they all have online and all of the
reviews are absolutely
incredible it seems like marvel has
completely crushed it with one division
as if anybody had any doubt that they
would so we'll go over
a bunch of reviews in this video talk
about what all the media outlets are
saying about the show about elizabeth
olsen about paul bettany and about the
overall vibe
of the show so if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest one division and
mcu news so to start this off we'll
start off with
stephen weintraub from collider and he
says have seen the first three episodes
of one division and
love how big of a swing marvel studios
is taking with the series
the reason the mcu is king of the hill
is kevin feige's amazing leadership and
willingness to take risks
like what you'll see in one division a
lot of people asked me about the length
of the one division episodes the first
three episodes are about 1 hour and 30
minutes i think the episodes get longer
as we get further into the series now
it has been confirmed that the first two
episodes are about 30 minutes each
and it's safe to assume that marvel
studios will somewhat follow
what lucasfilm did with the mandalorian
and that means that each episode may not
be the exact same length
some episodes of the mandalorian were 40
minutes 50 minutes to an hour each they
weren't all the same
so steven weintraub saw the first three
episodes and said it took about an hour
and 30 minutes so we can assume that
they're about 30 minutes each
and from his review it sounds like
marvel studios really
is trying something different when he
says they took a
big swing but he says they nailed it and
that marvel studios is king of the hill
the next review is from eric goldman of
fandom
and he says i've seen the first three
episodes of one of vision and man
it's my jam if you fret that all
superhero stories can feel the same
here is big proof otherwise i found it
delightfully trippy
and intriguing i love what i've seen so
far and can't wait to see the entire
season
the entire cast of one of vision is
great and fully committed to the
stylized approach
but elizabeth olsen's performance is
truly outstanding and one of those
man if awards shows weren't snobby about
superhero stuff she would likely get an
emmy nomination situations that's
something that has always kind of bugged
me how hollywood tends to write off
superhero shows for emmy nominations and
how they write off movies for other
nominations as well
because as you see here as we go through
more and more reviews people are raving
about elizabeth olsen's acting
saying that she absolutely crushed it
and isn't that really what the awards
are supposed to be about
it shouldn't really matter if it's in a
superhero tv show or not acting
is acting so hopefully they can look
past the whole superhero tv show part
and strictly judge her on her
performance because if she is as good as
everybody's saying she is she definitely
deserves at least a nomination
now i really like this comment because
he says that if you fret that all
superhero stories can feel the same
here is big proof otherwise now of
course we've already seen from the
trailers that this show is going to be
pretty different than anything we've
seen from marvel studios
which is awesome you have to do
something different to keep people
entertained and it sounds like marvel
studio has hit the nail on the head with
the one division series
the next review is from tanya lam who is
a critic for rotten tomatoes
and she says one division it's a gas
after screening the first three episodes
i'm hooked fun clever and marvelous the
quirky 30-minute sitcom style leaves you
wanting another episode each time
now this is really nice because
sometimes it's really hard to get a good
review from some rotten tomato critics
but tanya seems to have loved the series
the next review is from james viscardi
from comicbook.com
and he says we knew one vision was going
to offer a much different view of the
mcu
and boy does it most of the sitcom setup
of the show makes the reality of the
situation moments
incredibly tense and gripping how one
division approaches what we think is
normal
and what isn't makes it an incredibly
fun watch just three episodes in
i am impressed at how much it offers
fans waiting for mcu content while still
showing restraint
now again in this review we hear about
how different the series is
and anytime somebody tries to do
something very different
it could go either very well or very
poorly
it's very rarely in between it's usually
one or the other very good or very bad
and judging on all of these comics
marvel studios has done an
excellent job and it is very good now
one thing that particularly caught my
attention about this review is that he
said i am impressed at how much it
offers fans
waiting for mcu content while still
showing restraint
that's actually really nice to know
because marvel studios knows that we've
been waiting for content for a very long
time
and one division was not originally
supposed to be the first
project of phase 4 that was supposed to
premiere but of course
now it is and it's good to know that
they didn't do too much fan
service with the first three episodes
just because we've been waiting
they've stuck true to the story but have
completely blown people away with what
they showed
that's proof right there that marvel
studios and kevin feige
really do know what they're doing the
next review comes from the twitter
account at mama's geeky a writer for
screen rant and a critic at rotten
tomatoes and she says in her review
if the first three episodes of wanda
vision are any indication of what is in
store for us
we are in for a wild and crazy ride this
show is banana pants crazy in the best
possible way weird fun and simply
amazing it feels so very good to be back
in the mcu
again another great review calling it
crazy but in an
amazing way i think if there's any word
that could describe
one division so far based off of these
reviews it's crazy
but again everybody says that marvel
studios nails in they do it just
right not over the top not
underperforming and not crazy
in a bad weird way but a good weird way
the next one comes from charles murphy
over at murphy's multiverse.com and he
says that one division is the perfect
way for marvel studios to introduce
itself
if this is what marvel studios tv is
going to be
fans are going to be happy for a very
long time
this is a pretty exciting review because
he says that it's a good way for marvel
to introduce itself and there are going
to be a lot of people who have disney
plus
who may not be the biggest marvel fans
or maybe just casual marvel fans
who end up watching the show just
because they have disney plus and it's
on it but end up falling in love with
the series and therefore marvel
so again i think it's really awesome
that marvel's doing something so
different and they're nailing it
and then we have a review from dorian
parks over at geeks of color and he says
watched three episodes of wanavision and
the show is weird as hell
in a good way two things are clear one
marvel is dedicated to parading
classic sitcoms and two the mcu is
finally back
can't wait to see how this show sets up
doctor strange ii and spider-man 3.
it sounds like the first three episodes
didn't dive too much
into the different realities part of the
show and if they did they definitely
can't say anything about how it did tie
into that
but again another review stating that
the show is weird as hell but
in a very good way and for our last
review we have eric davis over at
fandango
and he says i've watched three episodes
of one division and have
thoroughly enjoyed it truly unlike
anything marvel studios has done
it's light funny and fully committed to
its retro sitcom inspirations but it
also carefully
sprinkles in enough mystery and intrigue
to keep you guessing well it sounds like
marvel studios
nailed it with the sitcoms that they're
recreating i know some people were kind
of worried about that but absolutely
zero complaints here from
any of the reviews i think every review
said that it was either crazy or weird
but in a very good way
and almost all of them said or implied
that it was very different than anything
that we've seen from marvel studios so
far
and overall it sounds like marvel
studios and kevin feige
elizabeth olsen and paul bettany
absolutely crushed it with one division
so one division premieres january 15th
next
friday i'll be doing a watch party on
january 14th
at 12 a.m if you want to join me be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the notifications
like this video if you're pumped for one
of vision and let me know how excited
you are for it in the comments down
below
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof